bonsoir
la vocation de cartes sur table et vous
le savez déjà et d'essayer d'aller au
delà du simple entretien
nous allons essayer ce soir avec alain
duhamel et surtout l'invité de ce soir
que je remercie monsieur jacques chirac
ancien premier ministre et président du
rpr
alors monsieur jacques chirac vous venez
de répéter au point ça fait un certain
bruit que le président de la république
n'est plus le chef de la majorité
vous avez dit aussi que ce n'était pas
monsieur bart qui conduirait la majorité
pendant la campagne électorale
alors ce sera vous jeudi également
je suis là mais les scoops assez bien
informés vous avez pu l'observer ou le
noter
j'ai dit également qu'il s'agissait là
en réalité d'une fausse querelle
il ya dans la majorité certains nombre
de partis et de mouvements et chacun a
sa personnalité représente un courant de
pensée qui existent sur le plan national
expriment une sensibilité politique
la caractéristique de ces différents
mouvements et partis c'est de défendre
chacun à sa manière les mêmes valeurs
essentielles d'avoir une idée commune
sur le type de société qui correspond le
mieux aux françaises et aux français et
qui est une société de responsabilité de
liberté alors à partir de là
naturellement chacun a aussi certain
nombre de convictions qui les conduisent
à avoir entre des divergences de vues
mais rien sur l'essentiel
mais pourquoi est ce une fausse querelle
parce que à partir du moment où vous
avez cette situation politique
vous pouvez difficilement imaginer que
l'un ou l'autre ou quelqu'un monsieur
duhamel me demande si j'ai la prétention
de conduire la majorité pouvait
difficilement imaginer que l'une des
parties s'impose aux autres c'est tout à
fait inimaginable de surcroît ce serait
sans aucun doute mauvais pour l'ensemble
car chacun à son type d'électeurs
présente son type de sentiments
politiques et par conséquent ce qui est
important c'est la coordination entre
ces différents partis et mouvements de
façon à se présenter unie pour la
bataille des saisies alors justement
jusqu'à présent la coordination c'était
le premier ministre dans la campagne
législative et puis au dernier moment
celui qui l'incarnait c'était le
président de la république oui dans le
passé monsieur duhamel dans le passé
nous avions dans le cadre nos
institutions et c'était de droits non
écrit en fait c'était une réalité
politique
une option qui étaient des prises qui
était prise par les présidents de la
république c'était vrai du général de
gaulle c'était vrai de monsieur pompidou
au terme de laquelle il ne faisait de
doute pour personne qu'ils assumer
personnellement la responsabilité de
leur majorité ce qui les conduisait à
s'engager eux mêmes dans le combat
politique au moment des élections
législatives s'étaient rue du général ça
a été vrai de monsieur pompidou à partir
de là naturellement il en tirait un
certain nombre de conclusions et
notamment il excluait la possibilité de
rester dans le cas où leur candidat
aurait été battue global 6 il
s'engageait l'année l'autre législatives
aucun d'envisager de rester si il
envisageait de rester si la majorité
étaient battus nous avons vérifié
nous avons vérifié et jamais général de
gaulle pompidou ont annoncé à la veille
des législatives qu'il se retirerait
dans l'opposition gagné ni en 58e 62e
néant 60 cents à 90 80 73 et vous savez
que le texte le plus connu est celui de
la conférence de presse le monsieur
pompidou du 21 septembre 72 qui disait à
peu près au lendemain des élections et
quels que soient ces élections je serai
amené à former un gouvernement
il faudra que ce gouvernement ne soit
pas renversé par l'assemblée et s'il est
renversé j'aurai la possibilité si je le
veux de dissoudre et de faire appel au
pays mais vous dites c'était valable
dans le passé qu'est ce qui a changé
aussi c'est une seule canne et permettez
moi de vous dire tout d'abord qui n'a
jamais fait de doute pour personne et le
général les illustrer
alors qu'il n'était absolument pas
obligés lorsque le référendum de 1969
n'a pas été positif pour lui c'est fait
un référendum bien sûr il ne fait de
doute pour personne que ni le général de
gaulle ni monsieur
bidou pourrait envisager de rester et de
présider un conseil des ministres qui
soit composée de socialistes et de
communistes
d'ailleurs veille des élections de la
façon la plus claire il s'était engagé
monsieur pompidou et même année si vous
vous en souvenez bien jusqu'à s'engager
entre les deux tours des élections de
1973 avec d'autres phrases ne l'indiqué
clairement et publiquement dans une
autre conférence de presse de quel droit
monsieur mitterrand prétend qu'il me
gardera s'il gagne et c'est tout ceci
était à l'époque tout à fait claire
naturellement ça n'a jamais été exprimée
de façon aussi nette pour une raison
simple c'est qu'un homme d'état ne fait
pas connaître à l'avancé la position qui
sera la sienne dans une conjoncture qui
n'est pas encore arrivé qu'il ne connaît
pas mais c'était tout à fait naître vous
faites allusion à une phrase que vous
détacher de son contexte du président
pompidou il ajoutait même si vous voulez
avoir la réalité et la vérité historique
bien que vos confrères ont entendu de sa
bouche il ajouté même et ce gouvernement
que je nommerais je le ferais présidée
par michel debré ce qui en réalité
exprime est de sa part une sorte
d'ironie sur des événements qui n'avait
rien de plaisant mais pourquoi si c'est
en lui tout juste l'assocation
aujourd'hui est tout à fait différente
le président de la république a une
autre conception de nos institutions qui
est d'ailleurs parfaitement légitime et
que personne ne peut contester puisque
seuls détenteurs de la légitimité par
son élection il est seul à même écart
tient de la constitution il est seul à
même de l'interpréter comme il le
souhaite
et dans le cas particulier il interprète
tout à fait au pied de la lettre
rien n'oblige le président de la
république a assumé sa majorité
rien ne l'obligé à démissionner si cette
majorité est battu mais le fait
d'indiquer clairement que son option est
de rester comme président de la
république
si la gauche gagne s'il y avait une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale et donc
un gouvernement et un premier ministre
de l'union de la gauche transforme
complètement les données du problème
interne d'abord ça affaiblit la majorité
incontestablement car nombreux sont
celles ou ceux qui ne seront pas très
bien compte de ce qui va se passer parce
que la fois ils sont un peu éloignés des
réalités politiques et qui se disent au
fond c'est très
bien on mettra monsieur giscard
d'estaing à l'elysée monsieur matignon
monsieur mitterrand à matignon et tout
ça sera pour le mieux dans le meilleur
des mondes
là ça ne se passera évidemment pas du
tout comme ça la majorité n'est plus
supportée par le président d'agir ça
change tout vous disiez tout à l'heure à
propos de monsieur pompidou et à propos
des présidents de la vème république
qu'il ne s'agit pas de révéler à l'avant
sa stratégie pourquoi ne pas penser que
le président giscard d'estaing ne
révélera pas à l'avant toute sa
stratégie étant donné qu'il a tout de
même dit qu'il indiquera le moment venu
c'est le bon choix oui pour le pays
laissez donc vous êtes une sorte
d'engagement officiel gavach le
président de la république a été
parfaitement clair il avait
effectivement qu'à la veille des locaux
avant les élections il a indiqué le bon
choix
c'est à dire ce qui lui semble
souhaitable et on ne peut pas douter du
fait qu'il se prononcera contre le choix
du programme commun mais il a indiqué
aussi de la façon la plus claire que
qu'en cas de victoire de la gauche il
maintiendrait les institutions et
resterait à l'elysée ce qui a pour
conséquence qu'ils n'assument pas
politiquement sa majorité actuelle et
donc qu'il ne veut pas et d'ailleurs il
n'a pas exprimé le désir de le faire la
conduire au combat politique
et s'il ne le fait pas contrairement à
ce qu'ont fait ces prêts nécessaires
personne ne peut le faire par délégation
et nous en revenons à la nécessité de
trouver entre les différents partis et
mouvements de la majorité les moyens que
nous trouverons car nos divergences de
vues sont très modestes mais vous vous
qui êtes profondément gaulliste ça ne
vous choque pas de voir que les leaders
de la montée des partis qu'ils aient la
majorité auront à définir eux mêmes et
entre eux qui conduira on ne revient pas
à plonger prochaine grâce islam nova
c'est que nous révisions ont critiqué
non je ne suis pas favorable au système
des partis je ne considère plus
qu'aujourd'hui nous soyons dans le
système de la vème république tel que
nous l'avons connu dans le passé mais en
revanche je ne permettrai certainement
pas de critiquer l'interprétation que
donne de la constitution le président de
la république il est seul à même de le
faire et je ne me permettrais aucun
critique sur ce point et sl majorité
peut se passer d'un chef pendant la
campagne et c'est les jo de pékin mais
je répète que là encore c'est un faux
problème
comment va se passer la campagne
électorale
je ne parle pas de la gauche si ce n'est
pour dire qu' elle même à des problèmes
internes importants et qui se manifeste
actuellement de façon je dirais criante
dans la mesure où les partis qui la
composent eux ont des divergences de vue
sur l'essentiel ce qui n'est pas le cas
des partis et mouvements de la majorité
sur le plan de la majorité nous avons
j'ai proposé dans un premier temps de
faire un pacte majoritaire qu'est ce que
cela veut dire ça veut dire ça plante
n'est pas naturellement un impact de
deuxième tour je sais quelles alliances
électorales de deuxième tour ça veut
dire simplement que les partis et
mouvements de la majorité prendrait
l'engagement de ne donner leur
investiture dans chaque circonscription
cas des candidats ayant préalablement
accepté de signer et de rendre publique
une déclaration selon laquelle ils
appartiennent à une certaine famille
politique qu'il défend d'un certain type
de société et qu'en conséquence il
exclut toute polémique entre eux à
partir du moment où il représente la
même majorité et que celui qui sera le
mieux placé par le scrutin par le
suffrage populaire au premier tour
restera seul mais avec l'appui militants
des autres le cas échéant pour défendre
nos options face au candidat unique de
la gauche au deuxième tour saxe est une
c'est un accord clair qui n'est pas et
qui permettrait d'avoir une certaine
détente dans la majorité qui est
parfaitement conforme aux règles
républicaines et démocratiques
si vous voulez nous y reviendrons mais
de toute façon ça donne une prime à
celui qui a le plus grand nombre de
sortants de toute façon je ne suis pas
je connais cet argument je n'en suis pas
du tout convaincu c'est d'abord une
affirmation claire sur le plan politique
tout le monde peut la comprendre elle
est conforme aux règles de la démocratie
au jeu de la politique telle qu'on la
conçoit dans notre vie tel qu'on le
conçoit dans notre république
mais ensuite je n'ai jamais dit qu'il
fallait qu'il y ait des primaires sur le
bal des primaires c'est-à-dire des
candidats représentant les différentes
forces de la majorité dans chaque
circonscription
on peut parfaitement estimé j'ai appelé
ça la procédure d'entendre si vous
voulez on peut l'appeler comme on veut
j'ai indiqué très clairement qu'il y
avait un certain non
deux circonscriptions un certain nombre
de cas dans lesquels l'intérêt général
de la majorité suggéré qu'il y ait un
candidat unique et qu'il appartenait au
mouvement est parti de la majorité de
s'entendre je suis moi même tout à fait
très naturellement pour déterminer quel
est l'intérêt global de la majorité dans
ce domaine chirac nous y reviendrons si
vous m'aimez vous êtes vous êtes souvent
exprimé sur votre attachement aux règles
démocratiques de fonctionnement des
institutions et ses thermes est
essentiel pour les gaullistes
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que le
respect du suffrage universel impose
même à un président un président en
exercice de conserver ses fonctions et
de l'exercer avec tous les moyens de
redresser le gavage je n'ai pas à porter
de jugement sur les options qui ont été
prises par le président de la république
me semblait regretter qu'il n'ait pas et
je travaille son souhait de l'artiste
peut parfaitement regretté que le
président de la république n'est pas
éprouvé le besoin de conforter sa
majorité en s'engageant totalement à sa
tête ce qui aurait réglé tous les
problèmes de chef de la majorité cher à
monsieur duhamel et en indiquant que
naturellement il ne pourrait pas
continuer à exercer la mission qui lui a
été confié par le peuple à partir du
moment où ce même peuple lui enlever les
moyens de l'exercer
je peux effectivement le regretter mais
ce n'est pas à le juger
le président de la république a été
investi la légitimité populaire il est
le gardien de vos institutions le garant
de la constitution et c'est à lui de
juger de l'interdiction qui lui donne
mais c'est un fait politique qui
applique naturellement certain nombre de
conséquences
alors justement à propos du président de
la république en 1974 vous avez joué un
rôle important pour l'aider à être élu
bon depuis que vous avez quitté le
gouvernement et vous êtes arrivés
plusieurs reprises d'être en désaccord
avec lui pour de l'europe en tout cas
certaine banalité
à propos quelquefois de la politique
économique de son gouvernement ou de
certaines de ses modalités à propos de
sa conception des institutions où
certaines de ses modalités
ce que vous regrettez
de l'avoir aidé comme vous l'avez fait
efficacement en 74 e mail si nous
revenions par un coup de baguette
magique au jour triste et pénible qui
ont été pour moi parmi les plus durs que
j'ai vécu de 1974 c'est à dire ceux qui
ont vu le départ de georges pompidou jeu
reprenait exactement la même position
politique et ceci pour une raison simple
c'est que le choix en 1974 à mes yeux
pour la majorité et à partir du moment
où il y avait une multiplicité de
candidatures n'était pas un choix
d'hommes car les différents candidats
exprimé en réalité la même ambition
fondamental en ce qui concerne l'avenir
de la nation et l'avenir de notre
société
c'était un choix consistant à permettre
que l'un d'entre eux se trouve au
premier tour placé un niveau tel qu'il
puisse battre monsieur françois
mitterrand au deuxième tour et
l'expérience constante en matière
politique prouve que si l'on est en
dessous d'un certain niveau au premier
tour on ne remonte pas le handicap et on
ne peut pas franchir la barre haut au
deuxième tour et donc le problème pour
moi était celui ci et comme monsieur
giscard d'estaing était manifestement
mieux placé que monsieur chaban delmas
pour le premier tour des élections
présidentielles il était essentiel de
faire en sorte que monsieur giscard
d'estaing arrive un niveau qui lui
permettent de franchir la barre c'est
l'autre mexpé merci au deuxième tour le
problème se reposera d'ailleurs dans les
mêmes conditions en 1978 pour les
élections législatives
les élections législatives seront
probablement gagné par la majorité qu'en
1978 pour une raison simple c'est
qu'actuellement le principal mouvement
politique de cette majorité c'est à dire
le rpr connaît un accroissement de son
impact politique qui ne fera que
continuer jusqu'aux c'est jusqu'à ces
élections jusqu'à atteindre un niveau
que je situe aux alentours de 30% et qui
lui permettra au premier tour d'être
situé de façon telle qu'il entraînera
l'ensemble de la majorité à franchir la
barre
ça veut dire qu'il faut que le rpr soit
sensiblement plus fort que ses
partenaires pour que l'ensemble de la
majorité gagne
j'en suis pour ma part persuadé et de
toute façon ce n'est pas une question de
choix ou de credo c'est tout simplement
une question de réalité dans l'état
actuel des choses et on n'imagine pas le
mal qu'elle puisse se transformer
considérablement d'ici neuf mois dans
les tacles des choses le fpr est le plus
important des mouvements de la majorité
ce qui n'enlève rien à la qualité au
dynamisme des autres mouvements de la
majorité c'est un fait politique et il
est important pour la majorité d'avoir
un élément solide puissant qui sera et
qui nous ne peut pas ne pas être un
élément d'entraînement et qui lui
permettra de franchir cet obstacle au
deuxième tour et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je suis très optimiste
vous savez on may a fait un procès
certains moments en indiquant que je
pouvais penser à une stratégie de
recours c'est à dire considérer que nous
serions battus aux élections
législatives de 78 ce qui était
important cette semaine dans une
situation politique et qui permettent au
rpr et éventuellement ceux qui
pourraient le rejoindre ou leurs alliés
d'être fort est bien placé pour un
éventuel recours après les élections
c'est une thèse absurde et en tous les
cas qui n'a jamais ni de près ni de loin
était la mienne je contraire fait une
analyse tout à fait différente
je considère que pour un certain nombre
de raisons sur lesquelles je suis tout
près d'ailleurs vous donner des détails
normalement la majorité doit gagner en
1978 et c'est après avoir fait cette
constatation après avoir acquis c'est
toute la majortié on le lance un
ensemble de la majorité de la majorité
naturellement et c'est après avoir
acquis cette conviction et avoir fait
cette constatation que j'ai arrêté une
stratégie pour le mouvement que je
préside et qui n'est pas piqué le
contraire d'une stratégie de recouvre et
qui est une stratégie offensive
immédiate et vous voyez que c'est celle
que
conduit actuellement et qui consiste à
mettre toutes ses forces dans la
bataille et immédiatement de façon à
avoir le maximum de chances de gagner
dès le premier tour de table
est-ce que c'était ce que ce qui met la
majorité aujourd'hui en position
difficile
ça n'est pas le fait qu'elle a eu des
divisions affichées est ce que dans ses
divisions affichées chacun des
partenaires n'a pas eu son rôle
vous avez d'abord quand il y a dans une
famille querelle
l'expérience prouve que les torts sont
toujours partage donc qu'attendre autres
je n'aurai pas du tout et bien et nous
et nous il est manifeste que certaines
nos partenaires ont trouvé que nous
avions au trop tendance à prendre des
distances à l'égard du chef de l'état
que nous avions trop tendance à affirmer
certaines de nos conceptions sans
prendre suffisamment garde à ceux qui
étaient les leurs ce tout ça est
possible que nous avions parfois une
certaine agressivité tout ça est
possible et nous avons naturellement les
mêmes reproches de forme d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus que de fonds à l'égard de
nos partenaires le problème n'est pas de
savoir où sont les auteurs quand il ya
une querelle
ils sont je répète toujours partagé
c'est la même chose dans les familles ce
qui est important c'est de savoir qu'il
n'y a rien de fondamentalement différent
par la différence entre la majorité et
l'union de la gauche c'est que la
majorité est une famille alors elle peut
de temps en temps ce que révélait avoir
des divergences d'intérêts avoir des
réactions un peu passionnel être un peu
agressive à l'égard des uns ou des
autres
et lorsque l'essentiel est en jeu la
famille en général se regroupent c'est
la caractéristique de la famille c'est
celle de la majorité alors que l'union
de la gauche n'était pas du tout une
famille c'est un club c'est une
association est constituée de gens qui
sont profondément différents et qui sont
liées par un simple souci qui est celui
de prendre le pouvoir
alors naturellement leurs querelles sont
beaucoup plus profondes
elles sont également plus masqué dans la
mesure où cette ambition de prendre le
pouvoir les conduit naturellement à
prendre le moins de risques possibles
par l'affichage de ces querelles encore
qu'en ce moment ça prenne une certaine
allure dans la mesure où l'on voit bien
que le parti communiste en réalité et la
partie forte de cette association
mais enfin ça fait une différence
fondamentale avec les no qu'est ce que
vous trouvez que le parti communiste et
la partie fort de l'association jure
françois mitterrand au congrès de nantes
vient de montrer qu'il était m au parti
socialiste le parti socialiste est le
premier parti électorale maintenant
nettement la vue aux municipales on l'a
vu aux cantonales on l'a vu dans les
élections partielles
duhamel je ne conteste pas que monsieur
mitterrand soit le maître de son parti
pas du tout encore que j'observe que la
fraction gauchistes de ce parti et la
faction crs est de plus en plus
dynamiques de plus en plus c'est un peu
ma femme là où il me recevait ce coup
mais très facile dans un congrès
politique chacun le sait ne nous faisons
pas d'illusions d'organiser les choses
sont ce que globalement le parti s'en
tire le mieux possible et non on avait à
faire et je n'ai pas oui avant il
s'adresse aux lycéens tout ceci
naturellement il n'en reste pas moins
que la fraction crs la fraction
gauchiste est une fraction extrêmement
forte et extrêmement dynamique et
qu'elle existe on ne peut pas le
contester
c'est ainsi vous savez on à l'histoire
se reproduisent souvent même de façon
lointaine je me souviens qu'en 1970 on
parlait beaucoup de l'expérience de
monsieur aliens des celi a élu un
président de la république qui était un
socialiste mais qui était disant modérés
parmi les socialistes et qui a eu à cet
égard l'apport d'un certain nombre de
voix modérées et quatre mois après
qu'est ce qui s'est passé est bien la
tête du parti a été prise par ceux qui
étaient les minoritaires c'est le
monsieur chevènement chilien et qui
s'appelait monsieur altamirano qui a
pris la tête du parti et on a vu ce que
ça a donné ça s'est terminé dans
l'aventuré et enfin naturellement dans
la dictature ce qui arrive elle a
souvent dans ce genre d'aventuré
non il ne faut pas sous estimer la
puissance réelle d'une fraction du genre
de celle du crs regarder quand il s'est
agi d'un combat important sur le plan
politique celui de paris pour la mairie
de paris se souvient de la réunion du
jury autour de cette même table pendant
la campagne
qui est-ce qui a été désignée comme
candidat à la mairie de paris par le
parti socialiste
c'est l'un des membres les plus éminents
du crs mais l'uci lui bah oui j'entends
bien qu'il est chez lui
d'autres socialistes qui sont également
chez eux n'est ce pas un pari le seul
socialiste de paris
non monsieur fédération crs whipple oui
naturellement une cp des rations crs
mais c'est également tout à fait
significatif que le parti des et été
obligé d'accepter la candidature nomme
du crs pour poste qui manifestement
faisait partie des plus importants de
cette campagne est des plus contestées
de cette campagne municipale
enfin peu importe ce point non mais
pourquoi je le dis que le parti
communiste et le plus c'est ça votre
crise aux dimensions
vous avez en politique la force le poids
politique ne se pose pas en termes de
voix aux élections
c'est évidemment important d'avoir
beaucoup de voix ces mêmes déterminants
sont au moment des élections en
démocratie c'est même déterminant mais
ensuite quand il s'agit d'exercer le
pouvoir
ce qui est important c'est la volonté
c'est la capacité de l'exercice ce sont
les moyens que l'on peut mettre au
service de cet exercice
or où se trouve cette volonté cette
capacité ses moyens il se trouve dans le
parti communiste est uniquement
le parti communiste a une homogénéité
mais vous voyez une discipline une
solidité une capacité qui n'existe pas
dans le parti socialiste ait beaucoup
s'en fout chirac s'était il a démarré
hier et les soins et les moyens qui sont
extraordinaires et notamment le moyen
syndicats la cgt est un instrument
considérable ou demander si ça peut
servir encore et vous imaginez que l'on
va gouvernement mais on l'a beaucoup des
cantonales et des mines aussi mal à
empêcher mais ça n'a effectivement rien
à voir je ne dis pas que c'est un
argument qui est orale c'est pas du tout
ce que je veux dire
tadic c'est une réalité politique la
réalité politique c'est que quand on dit
que le parti socialiste est le premier
parti de france dans le goulot premier
parti d'union de la gauche censée
hâtivement c'est vrai ça n'a pas de sens
c'est vrai en pro c'est probablement
vrai nous le verrons prochaines
élections c'est probablement vrai en
termes de voix ce n'est certainement pas
vrai en terme de puissance politique et
ce n'est en aucun cas vrai en terme de
puissance de gouvernement et c'est ça
qui est important
donc donc à notre avis si françois
mitterrand gagné aussi la bourgogne et
élections si françois mitterrand par
hypothèse était premier ministre ce
serait quelqu'un qui se laisserait
facilement manoeuvre par ses alliés
facilement certaines n'ont pas compétent
et justement c'est pour ça que vous
l'avez ville gens stressés qu on avait
déjà dit oui oui mais alors justement
fait tout à fait ma conviction
seulement la réalité du pouvoir la
capacité ou l'intelligence d'un homme
est une chose mais la réalité du pouvoir
c'est autre chose et la réalité du
pouvoir ce sont les communistes qui en
ont les moyens et qui ont les moyens de
l'affirmer et c'est un problème qu'il
convient aujourd'hui d'apprécier qui
doit faire l'objet d'une réflexion
d'après vous dans cette hypothèse en
1977 s'appuyant sur la cfdt que monsieur
mitterrand va gouverner en 77 d'après
vous dans cette hypothèse est ce que
vous voyez des ministères tabou que les
communistes ne peuvent pas voir parce
que par exemple a vraiment du mitterrand
a dit très justement que le problème
n'était pas de savoir si on allait
partager l'émotion d'organiser le monde
ici rien c'est peut-être la tâche de
monsieur marché le parti communiste a
affirmé depuis un mois de façon beaucoup
plus précise que par le passé quel était
son objectif et son ambition qui est de
gouverner
il a affirmé en disant qu'elles étaient
les exigences du parti communiste en
matière de participation au gouvernement
elles ont d'ailleurs été à mon sens
modeste et il a toute chance davout de
voir croître ses exigences sans aucun
doute à mon sens quand même si me terrel
a surtout affirmé
mais il a surtout affirmé en termes
d'application du programme commun et
c'est ça qui est le plus important
lorsque le parti communiste a pris la
décision qui à mon avis a marqué un
tournant fondamental dans la situation
l'union de la gauche de chiffrer les
conséquences du programme skoda c'est à
dire de dire bien derrière les mots sur
lesquels nous nous sommes mis d'accord
derrière les illusions qu'entretiennent
les orateurs socialistes sur toutes les
tribunes sur toutes les estrades
d'ailleurs toutes les promesses vagues
et non précisées dans le temps il y à
une réalité économique et une volonté de
l'appliquer et ceci se traduit par un
certain nombre de conséquences
humanitaires l'oeuf une pleine page
disant voilà ce chiffrage je vous cache
pas que naturellement nous l'avons
étudié avec beaucoup d'intérêt et que
nous l'avons également soumis à nos
experts et aux ordinateurs n'a pas donné
envie de chiffres est votre programme
ça n'a aucun rapport je voulais toujours
dit que je n'étais pas favorable nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure à des
programmes
en revanche nous n'avons aucune critique
à faire au chiffrage de l'humanité il
est exact ce chiffrage aux nuances près
bien entendu aux virgule près et un
détail qui est important prêt qui est
qu'il n'est prévu aucune espèce
d'indemnisation pour les
nationalisations ce qui n'aurait
peut-être pas beaucoup d'importance aux
yeux de l'opinion publique s'il
s'agissait uniquement des grosses
nationalisation mais comme la situation
se traduira par une très importante
vague de nationalisations alors ça peut
poser un problème mais peu importe ce
point ce chiffrage est exact mais qu'est
ce qu'ils indiquent ces problèmes tout à
fait extraordinaire que le parti
socialiste et ceux qui se prétendent ces
économistes ne disent rien à ce sujet
ils indiquent très clairement que nous
allons avoir une société d'un type
totalement différent avec
une diminution sensible de
l'investissement avec une augmentation
importante de l'action des
administrations avec une remise en cause
fondamentale de notre commerce extérieur
avec la nécessité de nous isoler du
monde extérieur avec la certitude que
nous serons obligés de quitter l'europe
etc pourrait vous en parler
naturellement longuement j'aurai
l'occasion de le développer
pendant les communistes ont marqué très
clairement la limite de ce qu'ils
laisseront faire aux socialistes ils
leur ont dit très clairement vous tenez
un certain nombre de propos vous donner
un nombre de formules tout ça et
électorale c'est très bien mais la
réalité est celle qui sera mise en
oeuvre si nous gagnons est totalement
différente
il est bon ça aussi que je peux donner
tous les socialistes ont déjà un premier
pas c'est un chiffrage du parti
communiste suivi du hamel ça ne les
engage pas ça aussi ça montre à quel
point le parti socialiste n'est pas
sérieux dans ses affirmations le je
crois que un je crois que c'était lénine
qui disait les communistes ont
d'excellents politique mais hélas de
très mauvaises économistes ce n'est plus
vrai pour les communistes en tous les
cas pour les communistes français actuel
mais c'est resté vrai hélas pour les
marxistes socialiste car cela ne veut
rien dire de dire que ça ne les engagent
pas c'est une réalité
ils ont signé un programme ne peuvent
pas en permanence rester dans le vague
est dans le flou et se contenter de dire
qu'ils donneront tout à tout le monde et
tout de suite dans des conditions qui ne
sont pas précisés qu'ils ne peuvent pas
être chiffrée
les communistes sont logiques avec
mobilise la signature du programme
commun impliquent un certain nombre de
conséquences les voilà et c'est la
réalité personne ne peut la contester
hier les socialistes qui entretiennent
une illusion général et monsieur bart a
eu raison avec tout son talent lorsqu'il
a eu son face à face avec monsieur
mitterrand d'indiquer que si on écoutait
monsieur mitterrand le programme commun
était un programme d'illusions un
programme purement électorales et qui
effectivement avait pas beaucoup de
chances d'entrer en vigueur
mais j'ajouterai que si c'est un
programme de gouvernement alors ça ne
peut être que le programme communiste
monsieur chirac vous disiez tout à
l'heure et on notait propos de
l'attitude que vous avez au niveau du
rpr que c'est une attitude maintenant
plus offensive plus battante dès
maintenant pour les élections 1978
est-ce que c'est pas un peu le contraire
vouliez faire en décembre 67 vous
cherchez surtout à ouvrir et à élargir
en franc créant précisément de
rassemblement mais quelques vaches nous
avons fait ce que nous souhaitions faire
en 1976 qu'est ce que nous voulions
faire nous voulions simplement revenir à
une notion fondamentale du gaullisme et
qui est celle du rassemblement
c'est-à-dire de l'adhésion de toutes
celles et de tous ceux qui acceptent
certain nombre de principes que vous
connaissez bien et que nous avons
actualisé en définissant notre manifeste
qui a été approuvé par nos assises du 5
décembre dernier depuis qu'est ce qui
s'est passé nous avons considérablement
augmenter le nombre de nos adhérents
considérablement
nous sommes maintenant à près de 500
mille adhérents nous en étions bien loin
le sac de sang vous ne direz que les
noms des dix ans de cotisants vous me
direz que le nombre des militants n'est
pas significatif de la force politique
d'un parti ce qui est important c'est
bien sûr d'avoir des militants mais
c'est aussi d'avoir des électeurs mais
je vous dirais que de plus en plus nous
avons le sentiment et la certitude et
nous le voyons dans tous les
départements que de plus en plus
nombreux sont ceux et celles qui ne
s'étaient jamais engagés
indépendamment de ce qui nous avait
quittés par mécontentement et qui nous
rejoignent maintenant qu'ils ont adhéré
au rpr ou plus exactement qui se dispose
à voter pour nous les autres elle
importe donc donc le rpr comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure assurée en
grande partie la victoire c'est une
victoire de la majorité
alors est-ce qu'il sera en soixante dix
huit celui qui en quelque sorte imposera
aux proposera avec beaucoup trop de
force peut être à la fois son premier
ministre et les choix ou les
orientations volet économique au format
c'est une question qui se pose de
communaux ne confondons pas tout n'est
ce pas le
ce qui est important nous avons
aujourd'hui une représentation pop et
populaire qui est une représentation
finissante et
rien ne peut être fait dans un pays est
dans une démocratie
rien ne peut être fait sur le plan de la
république s'il n'y a pas une expression
politique qui a reçu un mandat du peuple
et qui soit je dirai tout à fait
illustre réellement ce peuple or notre
pouvoir législatif actuel
incontestablement et c'est normal dont
le batteur des élections l'assemblée qui
termine son mandat elle a été élue dans
un contexte politique totalement
différent c'était monsieur pompidou qui
était président de la république
monsieur messmer qui était premier
ministre
elle a été élue dans un contexte
économique totalement différent nous
étions en période d'expansion nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une période de
crise mondiale sur le plan économique
avec les conséquences sociales
il est aujourd'hui indispensable pour
faire face aux difficultés que nous
connaîtrons dans les prochaines années
pour que la france puisse sortir et
sortir bien de la crise qu'elle connaît
qu'il y ait d'abord l'expression d'une
nouvelle volonté politique nationale sur
laquelle pourra être appuyé une action
de redressement qui sera d'ailleurs une
action d'efforts il ne faut pas lui
aussi trompé nous pourrons y revenir car
situation de la france sera différent à
partir de là si ce que je pense
ce produit si ce que j'ai ce conte se
produit c'est à dire que la majorité
gagne
ils étaient dix langues au sein de cette
majorité le père aura une place
importante au moins aussi importante que
celle que connaît actuellement
probablement plus est cela le permettra
au niveau qui est le sien c'est-à-dire
du pouvoir législatif d'être vigilants
cela ne l'autorisera pas imposer quoi
que ce soit dans nos institutions le
premier ministre et désigné par le
président de la république il détient sa
légitimité du président de la république
et de rien d'autre c'est au président de
la république qu'il appartiendra à ce
moment-là de choisir son premier
ministre
certainement pas au rpr d'imposer quoi
que ce soit alors pour savoir justement
jusqu'où va l'unité
de la majorité vous avez révélé à
l'occasion du débat sur l'europe à
l'assemblée nationale que vous n'étiez
pas d'accord avec les prisons de la
république au moment où vous étiez
premier ministre sur l'attitude de la
france sur le problème européen loyer
question extrêmement simples mais
importantes qu'on se pose est-ce qu'ils
avaient d'autres points importants sur
lesquels vous n'étiez pas d'accord avec
lui quand vous étiez premier ministre
soutient mais je vais vous dire que dans
notre système politique
il ne peut pas y avoir de divergences de
vues entre le président de la république
et le premier ministre bly court erick
naturellement il ne peut pas y en avoir
égard si l'hiver chances de vue le
premier ministre doit s'en aller
ce n'est pas la lettre de la
constitution mais c'est son esprit
le premier ministre doit s'en aller soit
qu'il est remercié par le président de
la république soit ce qui a été mon cas
qu'il décide de mettre lui-même fin à
ses fonctions à partir de là je ne vous
dirais certainement pas et quelles
pouvaient être les divergences de vue
que j'avais avec le président de la
république lee deux jeunes les élèves et
je ne les avais jamais dit à qui que ce
soit même à mes collaborateurs les plus
étroits devait arriver bien souvent de
dire certain nombre de choses aubry dans
la république mais quand je sortait de
son bureau
c'était sa décision qui s'imposait et
qui était la mienne mais maintenant que
sans cela sans cela il n'y a pas de
gouvernement possible avec les
institutions les irish banks plc
j'ai fait une entorse à ce principe qui
est le mien à l'occasion du débat sur
l'europe
c'est simplement parce que j'étais 2
choqué par le fait d'avoir été
systématiquement mise en cause par
plusieurs ministres du gouvernement dont
un d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup d'amitié et
d'estimé mais qui ne siégeait pas à ce
chaos différents conseils auxquels il
faisait allusion je n'avais pas observé
qu'il était caché sous la table pour
entendre ce qui s'y disait et d'autre
part par le porte parole de l'elysée et
qui tendait à faire accroire que j'avais
changé d'avis et que je dis plein jour
et moins un autre alors j'ai donc un
look et non je dormais total total ainsi
que j'ai donc indiqué région il est
indiqué que j'avais eu effectivement des
divergences de vues et que sur ce point
je n'avais pas changé d'avis je n'en
donnerai aucun autre exemple j'ai
simplement la répondu mais je ne pourrai
certainement pas l'initiative de donner
d'autres exemples de cette nature
est ce que vous étiez déjà
démissionnaire et d'autre part rien vu
si je me rappelle bien parce qu on a
relu beaucoup de textes avant de vous
voir est ce que vous êtes manifester
lorsque par exemple il ya eu un après le
conseil des ministres un communiqué
disant qu'il veut un accord unanime du
gouvernement sur la question européenne
va gérer bien sûr ce point de la tribune
de l'assemblée nationale je ne
reviendrai pas sur cette affaire je n'ai
rien d'autre à dire parce que je dirais
de l'assemblée nationale pour changer de
thème tout en restant proche de l'ordre
si on veut est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec la façon dont le président de la
république maintenant on connaît le
premier ministe donc que vous exprimer
d'accord avec la façon dont il a défini
les relations de la france avec une
hausse des tic mme subra jeunesse vient
de partir ces questions qui se posent
vous savez pour les gaullistes
et je crois pour l'avenir de la france
que les relations entre la france et
l'union soviétique compte une importance
capitale
toute notre politique étrangère depuis
longtemps et toujours aujourd'hui est
fondé sur l'affirmation de notre
indépendance nationale
affirmation difficile dans le monde que
je connais sont devenus des
interconnexions constante qui existent
entre les différents pays ont tenu les
pressions des crises ou les difficultés
que connaît le monde moderne mais enfin
nous tenons à ce que la france reste
indépendante dans toute la mesure du
possible
cette indépendance suppose compte tenu
de la situation d'allier atlantique de
la france qu'elle et d'excellentes
relations avec union soviétique et que
par conséquent l'effort de coopération
avec l'union soviétique tant sur le plan
culturel qu'économique que politique
soit approfondie en permanence c'est la
raison pour laquelle je me réjouis du
voyage c'est fait monsieur vrai génie
havas paris me suis réjoui je pris
connaissance rapidement des communiqués
juste avant de venir ici et je me suis
réjoui de leur nature et de leur teneur
notamment celui sur la détente et je
trouve que c'est un pas de plus dans la
bonne direction c'est à dire celle d'une
entente franco soviétique est un élément
permanent de notre diplomatie est dans
notre intérêt
donc vous êtes d'accord tout à fait là
dessus je vais présenter en public tout
à fait est ce qu'il ya des points en
dehors de l'europe sur lequel les en
politique étrangère vous êtes en
désaccord mais non coûteux je ne vais
pas essayer de les énumérer rechercher
quels sont les points d'accord ou
désaccord chaque homme et chaque
mouvement politique a naturellement ses
aspirations ses alter et qui l'amène
avoir des divergences de vue mais qui
sont souvent de détails sur tel ou tel
point nous en avons eu 1 sur l'europe
chacun l'a connu nous sommes
profondément européen je les dis à
l'entreprise nous voulons la
construction d'une europe nous militons
pour la construction d'une europe qui
soit à la fois indépendante et
confédéral tout le monde en a
bien d'accord nous avons une divergence
de vue sur une procédure mais qu'ils ne
touchaient rien l'essentiel on l' a
grossi pour des raisons de politique
intérieure mais ça ne touche à
l'essentiel
vous avez refusé toute évolution du mode
de scrutin monsieur jacques chirac est
ce que c'est une position définitive ou
est-ce que vous accepteriez qu'on peut
voir le mode de scrutin qui
éventuellement en le révise après les
élections 78 particulier sur la
représentation proportionnelle c'est le
clash le scrutin ce n'est pas les votes
dessous la loi électorale ce n'est pas
un dogme
c'était un homme pour personne et chacun
sait que au rpr il y à de nombreuses
personnalités notamment que moi députés
qui seraient favorables à un changement
de scrutin est favorable à un scrutin
proportionnel
[Musique]
d'autres y sont hostiles je me suis
prononcé pour ma part et nous nous
sommes unanimes in an aussi bien aux
parlementaires du rpr comme venant
prononcé contre une modification de la
loi électorale pour deux raisons
fondamentales
la première c'est que nous craignons que
le scrutin proportionnel
nous nous fasse revenir à une certaine
instabilité de parlementaires que nous
avons connue sous la iiième sous la
quatrième république
car il risque de multiplier les petits
partis degré des partis charnières qui à
ce moment là ont des exigences
politiques souvenez-vous de certains
petits partis qui avec 15 membres
exigeait d'avoir six ou sept ministres
tout ceci n'était absolument pas dignes
ni efficace
il ya une deuxième raison c'est que
lorsque l'on est sorti il faut le dire
amoindri de deux consultations
électorales successives la consultation
cantonales et la consultation municipal
et que l'on est à la veille d'une autre
consultation électorale
eh bien on ne change pas la loi
électorale c'est une question je dirais
de morale et d'éthique
on conserve la même règle du jeu sinon
on donne l'impression que l'on veut
truqués pour ne rien vous cacher je
pense que la loi proportionnelle
ne seraient pas défavorables à la
majorité qui lui serait même
probablement favorables et notamment
qu'elle serait probablement favorable au
rpr j'observe d'ailleurs que les
socialistes qui ont toujours été
partisan de la loi proportionnelle ils
sont en fait aujourd'hui hostile parce
qu'elle leur serait l'embryon et ne
l'ont pas dit ils ne l'ont pas dit mais
parce qu'elle leur serait probablement
défavorable
ils ne l'ont pas dit musulman bien
laissé entendre qu'il leur serait
probablement des fables donc loin des
paillettes que c'est important
maintenant colonisation bloque nous
sommes en tous les cas
opposés à toute modification avant la
législation repose ma question mais
après j'ai écouté après nous verrons
vous êtes ouvert à la discussion nous
verrons vous tenez à la discussion après
oui enfin vous savez pour ce qui me
concerne personnellement je ne veux pas
sur ce point qui est important engagé le
mouvement par une déclaration prématurée
vous pouvez aller pour cet e-mail est
bien leur à titre personnel je vous
dirais que je suis profondément attaché
au scrutin uninominal soudain gt1
actuelles actuelle profondément attachés
pour des raisons de fond et donc je suis
hostile à la proportionnelle et pour une
raison simple c'est pour des raisons qui
tiennent à l'idée que je me fais de la
démocratie
nous sommes dans un monde où le
l'exécutif t2 le gouvernement quelles
que soient les régimes deviennent de
plus en plus fort parce que les
problèmes sont de plus en plus complexe
et qu'il faut une autorité forte pour
les régler maman france même en france
le c'est une c'est un si vous voulez
aller leur historique d'une constatation
historique les gouvernants sont de plus
en plus forts nécessairement parce que
les problèmes sont complexes et qu'il
faut les régler qu'il faut une autorité
pour cela si bien que si l'on veut
rester fidèle certain idéal démocratique
il faut qu'il y ait des contrepoids
nécessaire et notamment qu'il y ait un
parlement et que dans ce parlement siège
des hommes qui soit aussi proche que
possible de leurs électeurs et qui
exprime aussi bien que possible les
préoccupations quotidiennes et la
sensibilité des électeurs et des
électrices dans le scrutin uninominal le
député est forcément une expression
aussi bonne que possible de ses
préoccupations car il est au contact
permanent il doit connaître ses
électrices et électeurs s'il fait bien
son métier naturellement et au parlement
on a une sensibilité très direct et par
conséquent un contrepoids très
démocratique dans le scrutin
proportionnel
elle les candidats sont désignés d'abord
dans une circonscription beaucoup plus
grande et ce paquet le département et
sont désignés par les états majors des
partis ils sont donc beaucoup plus liées
pour leur désignation et pour leurs
intérêts aux états majeurs de parti
qu'au peuple réellement et c'est donc
vôtre - geely non dans le scrutin
majoritaire 110 - désigné par le nom
beaucoup moins parce qu'ils sont
il s'impose davantage quand candidat est
bien implanté comme on le dit on le dit
pour un scrutin majoritaire on le dirait
pas de la même façon comme au scrutin
proportionnel
il représente beaucoup mieux la
population parce qu'il la connaît notre
scout et on ne pas rester trop dans la
trop longtemps sur ce terrain de la
théorie politique
et puis revenons à des questions qui
peuvent être d'actualité par exemple on
nous dit que vers le 15 juillet vous
allez annoncer la liste des 500
candidats du rpr alors on ne vous a
jamais dit ça on l'a lu un enfant nous
mais oui je ne suis pas responsable de
tout ce qu'on écrit mais
nous sommes effectivement actuellement
en train sous la responsabilité et
l'autorité de monsieur yves guéna de
déterminer quels seront nos candidats
dans chacune des circonscriptions et je
pense effectivement que vers la mi
juillet le travail sera donc ces départs
frais engagés s'était propagé à dire
nous ne publierons pas de liste le 14
juillet alors vous vous en prévoyez un
parent c'est conscription jeu monsieur
duhamel je vous ai dit tout à l'heure on
a effleuré ce problème touche 51 il est
important dans l'état actuel des choses
j'ai proposé un pacte majoritaire nos
partenaires de la majorité ne m'ont pas
encore répondu alors il est de la
responsabilité des responsabilités de
prévoir un candidats par circonscription
mais j'ai indiqué très clairement que
dans la mesure j'ai appelé ça un
processus de détendre d'entente et de
coopération
j'ai invité fait clairement que j'étais
tout à fait ouvert à des discussions
ayant pour objectif l'intérêt de la
majorité et qui permettrait de dégager
les circonscriptions il est souhaitable
d'avoir un candidat unique et donc
certaines circonscriptions où le rpr
n'aurait pas d'autre candidat combien
c'est 1,2 et combien de nos qu'une idée
connaissez bien la carte électorale je
connais la carte électorale mais enfin
je n'ai encore aucune idée ça dépendra
des discussions que nous pouvons avoir
avec nos partenaires nous serons nous
prêts à mettre un candidat par
circonscription dans les deux mois qui
viennent
ça c'est une chose claire à partir de là
nous serons également prêts à discuter
mais vous ne pensez pas que ce soit à
venir pour ça c'est une question
pratique importante vous pensez que le
plus efficace pour la majorité c'est
d'avoir le maximum d'entente ou d'avoir
le maximum de primaire vous savez on ne
peut pas répondre à cette question la
politique électorale c'est pas de la
théorie c'est en réalité quelque chose
qui est très proche du terrain et qui
doit être examinée circonscription par
circonscription
quand vous dites que j'ai
j'aurai un candidat pas circonscription
c'est une position mais il est évident
qu'il ya un certain nombre de
circonscriptions dans laquelle il est
souhaitable qui est un candidat unique
il faut l'apprécier cas par cas qui me
suit à 82 millions aujourd'hui
eh bien ce sont les représentants des
différents partis et mouvements de la
majorité qui discuteront ensemble et
qu'ils s'entendront ou qui ne
s'entendront pas eh bien s'ils ne
s'entendent pas y aura des primaires et
c'est pourquoi je demande un pacte
majoritaire préalable et s'ils
s'entendent ce que je souhaite et croyez
bien que nous y mettrons d'une autre à
ce moment là il y aura un candidat
unique de 2,2 question monsieur soissons
pour le père vous a demandé et a demandé
à tous les partenaires et responsables
de la majorité
une sorte de rencontre au sommet
problème deuxièmement cette discussion
deuxième question est ce qu'elle est
faite en l'absence totale du premier
ministre monsieur bart pas ce qui
n'apparaît pas j'aurais sans aucun doute
l'occasion de parler de ses problèmes
avec monsieur marc je lui en ai déjà
parlé et j'ai l'intention de le revoir
prochainement pour lui en parler mais là
il s'agit d'un problème je dirais de
cartes électorales de candidature dans
un système dont plus personne n'imagine
qu'il puisse se faire avec un arbitrage
et vous par conséquent il s'agit de
discussions entre les représentants
alors monsieur monsieur barre pendant la
campagne électorale c'est quelqu'un qui
interviendra beaucoup à votre avis qui
doit intervenir beaucoup je le souhaite
vous le souhaiter beaucoup de durban et
quelle quelle sorte de responsabilité de
prérogatives politiques vous pensez que
vous pourriez lui reconnaître au niveau
du rpr pape dansant une majorité mais
connaît monsieur elkabbach monsieur bart
qui est un premier ministre que nous
soutenons un bon premier nous respectons
pas toujours voulu nous lé pas toujours
que nous soutenons tous quand il faut
ouvrir excellent dans toute la mesure
quand il faut voter et dans toute la
mesure où ce qu'il nous propose n'est
pas contraire à nos options à nos
croyances
ce que nous estimons nécessaire pour la
france mais notre soutien ne lui a
pratiquement jamais fait défaut
nous n'avons pas
accepté de soutenir la sphère de
l'europe telle qu'elle nous était
présentée parce qu'elle nous
paraissaient dangereuses pour la france
mais nous n'avons pas pour autant
déposer une motion de censure et je me
suis expliquée sur ce point mais quelle
bouillie zouk et l'impressionnant nous
soutenons le gouvernement de monsieur
bah il ya aucun problème c'est mais
monsieur bart n'est pas à ma
connaissance membre du rpr et par
conséquent je ne lui reconnaît pas
effectivement le droit de trancher
pour ce qui concerne le rpr bien sûr pas
pour le rpm il faut être l'animateur le
coordonnateur de la majorité comme
l'avait été par exemple mais je ponds
pidoux en son temps mais vous méritez
tout à l'heure c'est la nation aucun a
changé monsieur pompidou quand il était
premier ministre était effectivement le
l'animateur le coordinateur de la
majorité et personne ne lui contester un
droit de décision et d'arbitrage mais
pour une raison simple c'est que ce
pouvoir lui été délégué par un président
de la république qui assumer totalement
sa majorité
vous venez de prononcer le nom de
monsieur bart c'est votre successeur
voudrait que c'est un bon successeur
écoutez j'ai proposé
au président de la république monsieur
bart entre au gouvernement
et je ne trahirai trahir et aucun secret
en vous disant que lorsqu'il a été nommé
premier ministre
je m'en suis beaucoup réjouie et je n'ai
aucune espèce de raison d'avoir changé
d'avis à cet égard il conduit une action
extrêmement difficile qui est difficile
pour des raisons politiques qui tiennent
ce que nous avons évoqué tout à l'heure
et qui est très difficile sur le plan
technique en raison de la crise et de
ses conséquences et qui est également
très difficile pour une autre raison que
l'on apprécié passer c'est que nous
sommes à la veille d'élections
législatives et qu'il est impossible
réalité de conduire une action de
redressement sans s'appuyer sur une
expression politique sur une nouvelle
volonté politique nationale et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'avais demandé que
des élections législatives soit faite
l'année dernière car je savais qu'on
était obligé de conduire une politique
de redressement et je savais que cette
politique de redressement de pouvait
avoir de chance d'être vraiment conduite
avec l'ensemble des réformes qui sont
nécessaires qu'à condition de s'appuyer
sur un pouvoir politique nouveaux et
nouvelles menthe exprimer ça signifie
concrètement dsm a réussi en larmes et
ce n'est des décennies surtout ses
racines on vend pas du tout qui ne peut
pas même sir ça signifie simplement et
c'est pourquoi nous soutenons son action
que cette action fondée sur une
expression politique qui est à venir et
qui n'est pas encore exprimés ne peut
être qu'une action de gestion ce qu'il
fait le mieux possible mais ce qui
m'intéresse moins ce qui me concerne ce
qui me préoccupe
ce n'est pas du tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous dis je n'ai aucune
critique à formuler sur l'action du
gouvernement et je la soutiens
mais ce n'est pas mon problème mon
problème c'est de savoir au lendemain de
l'élection en 1978 avec la nouvelle
majorité qui sera sorti des urnes avec
une expression démocratique nouvelle qui
aura été donné par les électrices et les
électeurs avec le nouveau mandat qu'ils
auront confié une majorité parlementaire
la politique qui pourra à ce moment là
est reconduit
et qui est une nouvelle politique j'ai
essayé d'expliquer dans le récent
discours vous le savez que le considérer
mais seulement après les élections qu'il
fallait faire une nouvelle politique de
l'économie fondée d'abord et avant tout
sur une priorité à donner à l'emploi
qu'il fallait faire une nouvelle
politique sur le plan social mais tout
ceci que j'ai exprimés que j'exprimerai
tout au long de la campagne électorale
n'est concevable qu après que le peuple
ait donné un mandat à une majorité
nouvelle et donc dynamique est forte et
capable de la confusion car ce sera un
grand effort elle avait répliqué quelque
chose que je ne comprends pas très bien
vous dites vous venez nous dire vous
d'être répété qu' après les élections il
faudrait qu'ils une nouvelle politique
qui soit déterminé dans laquelle vous
mettez des espoirs mais alors cette
nouvelle politique est ce qu'il faut pas
l'expliquer avant les élections français
autrement dit est-ce que en pratique la
majorité peut se passer d'avoir un
programme commun qui explique aux
français avant le vote ce qu'elle veut
faire
après les élections si elles gagnent
phénomène qu'elle est actuellement le
problème de la france telle que moi je
le vois et la france est dans une
période de crise naturellement elle en
sortira
comme tous ses partenaires et tout le
problème c'est de savoir si j'ose
m'exprimer ainsi dans quel état est d'en
sortir est ce que la france sortira de
la crise mondiale actuelle forte
respecter et au niveau de ceux qui en
sortiront le mieux dans lesquels on
trouvera sans aucun doute les états unis
le japon l'allemagne fédérale
ou est-ce qu'au contraire elle sortira
de cette crise diminués et par
conséquent affaibli c'est ça le grand
défi actuel de notre temps c'est une
situation qui par bien des côtés est
identique à celle que nous avons connu
cette période de l'histoire celle
contre laquelle a essayé de réagir un
homme comme pierre mendès-france c'est
une situation un peu identique
nous avons maintenant les moyens
institutionnels d'en sortir ce qu'il
faut c'est avoir la volonté politique
pour le faire et tout notre problème
aujourd'hui c'est de l'exprimer
nous allons donc pour notre compte le
dire pour votre compte en a vraiment
pour le rpr nous avons commencé et nous
allons dire clairement ce que nous
souhaitons l'arrondi d'un programme
commun de la majorité
vous savez nous ne sommes pas favorables
à la notion de progrès et ceci pour 273
et ceci pour deux raisons
non ce n'est pas un programme en série
ces virements des gens c'était une série
d'engagements de réalisation par un nous
sommes solidaires nous sommes hostiles à
la mission programme pour deux raisons
la première c'est lorsqu'un programme
forcément devient très rapidement
inadapté on le voit avec le programme
commun de gouvernement de l'union de la
gauche aujourd'hui qui est manifestement
totalement inadapté à la situation
actuelle puisqu'il a été fait dans une
pleine période d'expansion et au moment
où les données intérieur/extérieur
économiques et politiques et sociales
étaient complètement différent nous ne
voulons pas courir ce risque qui est en
réalité je dirais qu'ils expriment même
en réalité un certain mépris à l'égard
de l'électeur c'est vraiment de
l'électoralisme au sens le plus le plus
modeste du terme
et puis il ya une deuxième raison c'est
que pour faire un programme commun
il faut trouver naturellement des
compromis sur tout et si on trouve des
compromis surtout eh bien on perd un peu
de son âme
et aussi on perd de ses électeurs alors
il est beaucoup plus sage beaucoup plus
correct beaucoup plus honnête sur le
plan démocratique que nous disions
chacun quels sont nos ambitions ce que
nous pensons nous avons un système qui
est à deux tours et qui donc permettent
au premier tour de se prononcer en
faveur de telle ou telle appréciation
dans la majorité d'autant n'affichant
très clairement quelles sont nos
convictions communes sur l'essentiel et
qui seront celles qui seront défendus
par le candidat unique de la majorité
qui est au 2e tour affrontera le
candidat du
de l'union de la gauche chaque formation
de la majorité par hypothèse à son
programme explique ce qu'elle veut
oui il pas quelque chose qui s'objectent
c'est sympa mais chaque formation de
majorité elle explique à ses électeurs
pour essayer de les convaincre
bon il ya les élections hypothèse la
majorité gagne dont à ce moment là le
parti de la majorité qui aura le plus de
députés le plus de voix doit souhaiter
que ce soit ses objectifs à lui qui leur
a expliqué à ses élites oui vous
observerez monsieur duhamel que ceci est
tout à fait exacts mais que les
différents objectifs qui sont définies
par les différents mouvements et partis
politiques de la majorité sont très
proches les uns des autres
il appartiendra ensuite que son au
président de la république au
gouvernement de faire la synthèse de ces
objectifs et aux députés de faire de
s'exprimer de façon telle que
naturellement il ne trahissent pas le
mandat qui leur a été confiée ni à cet
égard pas de problème dans nos
institutions la chance d'avoir des
institutions qui permettent de gouverner
a l'impression que tout va commencer
demain je trouve que tout a commencé
déjà depuis un certain temps vous ne
vous disais par exemple récemment en
france le chômage n'est pas inévitable
or quand vous avez quitté le
gouvernement il y avait neuf cent mille
chômeurs recensés est ce qui vous aviez
une recette que vous n'avez pas pu
appliquer ou quelqu'un vous empêcher le
jeu vous aider je vous ai dit je le cas
match que d'une part je ne reviendrai
pas sur des hypothèses de divergences de
vue que j'ai pu avoir avec le
gouvernement je vous dirais également
que si j'ai pris moi même la décision de
mettre fin à mes fonctions c'est
probablement qu'il y avait des raisons
de fond parce que vous aviez là vous
aviez la réponse ou la zolie simplement
on n'a jamais de réponse ou de solution
qui soit certaine
disons que j'ai en tout les cas des
ambitions à cet égard je considère de
façon simple qu'un pays dans lequel il y
a le nombre que nous avons de chômeurs
je veux prononcerai pas sur ce nombre
car il ya des contestations des
divergences de vue sur ce point et mais
où il ya deux millions de travailleurs
immigrés
et qui a heureusement d'ailleurs je
témoigné cet égard l'importance qu'ils
ne sont à nos yeux pour notre économie
et où il ya la richesse que nous avons
et bien il y à une solution au problème
de l'emploi
et cette solution elle doit être
recherchée mais elle ne peut l'être la
condition qui est une volonté politique
de le faire ce sera l'un des thèmes de
notre programme qu'à condition de sortir
ce que l'on ne peut pas faire
aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça que nous
approuvons la politique de gouvernement
mais ce qu'on pourra faire demain si
nous en recevons le mandat la condition
de sortir je dirais des chemins battus
de la pensée économique traditionnel je
suis persuadé pour ma part qu'il faut
d'abord faire en sorte que l'emploi par
les actions notamment d'investissements
nécessaires soient ramenés à sa
situation normale c'est à dire une
situation de plein emploi
qu'ensuite on constate que cette
politique conduite un certain nombre de
déséquilibres sur le plan des finances
extérieures sur le plan de la monnaie
sur le plan des prix etc enfin dans un
troisième volet on prenne des
dispositions qui permettent de réduire
ces déséquilibres s'ils seront des
dispositions des fleurs et des
dispositions contraignantes ne nous y
trompons pas et c'est pour ça que ça
exige une vous ferez ce que vous n'avez
pas pu faire c'est parce que nous
faisons rien fait si vous n'avez pas vu
que je souhaiterais le faire oui mais
mais chronologiquement si c'est si j'ai
bien compris ce que vous me dire cette
vous mettez un petit peu les choses dans
l'ordre inverse
lombard mais je ne me trouve pas du tout
dans la même situation monsieur raymond
barre et confronter avec la réalité
quotidienne du gouvernent c'est plus
haut c'est extrêmement sérieuses et même
par à 109 pas je sais de quoi je parle
mais monsieur bart est confronté aux
réalités quotidiennes dans un système de
données il le fait il le fait avec notre
appui
moi ce qui m'intéresse ce n'est pas ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui ce qui
m'intéresse ce qui me concerne ce que je
veux proposer aux françaises et aux
français c'est que ce qui doit se passer
demain c'est le veulent et pour cela je
leur indiquerai clairement quels sont
vos objectifs et ils se prononceront
démocratiquement
s'il se prononce sur notre faveur je ne
doute pas que nous ayons le poids
politique qui nous permettra d'entraîner
les choses dans la direction que nous
estimons souhaitable pour la france et
des français
mais concrètement pour l'instant raymond
mardi rétablissons d'abord les
équilibres et le problème du chômage
sera je ne vois pas ce qui pourrait
faire d'autre aujourd'hui est dans la
situation actuelle et vous vous dites
pour demain après les élections vous
dites pour demain après les élections
réglons le problème du chômage
et puis on verra après pour les grands
équilibres et vous dites vous dites nous
sommes partisans nourrir père de la
majorité est en tout cas de l'unité mais
il n'y a pas de volonté politique vous
l'avais répété quatre à cinq fois vous
le dites crise très souvent et l'autre
par nos alliés de la majorité pas de
volonté politique
j'ai des kills il promet qu'il fallait
une nouvelle volonté politique nationale
qui ne peut sortir que des urnes pour
faire face aux grands défis qui est le
nôtre actuellement c'est à dire sortir
la france dans de bonnes conditions de
la crise que connaissent tous les pays
industriels actuels
c'est tout à fait différent parce que
vous parlez de l'unité ce qu'on croyait
pas mal de français qui vit un monde
vous croient pas ou ont du mal à vous
croire sur l'unité de la majorité
oui certainement car il ya eu dans la
majorité et nous en sommes tous
responsables certain nombre de
maladresses qui ont été commises vous
savez on ne fait pas de politique sans
faire de maladresse et mais je suis
certain que par le mouvement naturel des
choses par le fait qu'il n'y ait rien de
fondamental qui sépare les mouvements et
partis de la majorité il apparaîtra
clairement et bien avant les élections
que cette majorité va où
électorale unis donc il y aura des
initiatives probablement pacifique et
peut-être amicale de votre part dans les
semaines qui viennent c'est la période
de tension ainsi on est très déterminé
j'ai déjà fait un geste qui me paraît un
geste politiquement important en
proposant qu'il y ait d'un pacte
majoritaire et qu'à partir de la
signature de ce pacte majoritaire qui
est vite bien notre volonté d'être unis
et associés dans le même combat
on est à une entente qu'on est des
discussions qui nous permettent de
définir très clairement la façon dont
nous irons unie au combat
il ya eu l'europe après oui mais ça ne
change rien non je veux dire on a
toujours un petit peu le sentiment quand
on regarde la majorité point de vue nos
observateurs on a toujours le sentiment
que qui est des moments où on dit il
faut s'unir on va faire un pacte de
majorité et a aperçu le premier problème
politique un peu important qu'est posée
top on se mêle c'est elle c'est le
dernier je travaille à mon avis de se
passer tout à fait le dernier dire
qu'elle ne le rappelle dernier le
dernier vous divisez avant les élections
qu'ils pouvaient introduire au sein de
la majorité des appréciations
différentes ce qui est classique séance
mais si vous voulez mon sentiment je
suis persuadé que c'est le dernier car
je n'en vois pas d'autre le seul acte
politique important qui reste à
accueillir le légendaire proches
oui et puis le seul acte politique
important qui reste à accomplir c'est le
péché le budget je ne doute pas un seul
instant que
groupe parlementaire rpr sera conduit
bien sûr a demandé des modifications à
proposer des amendements mais qu'il sera
conduit à le voter
et d'ailleurs je dirais que ça n'a plus
beaucoup d'importance car au lendemain
des élections la nouvelle majorité qui
exprimera la nouvelle politique qui sera
conduite sera bien sûr amené à en tirer
des conclusions sur le plan budgétaire
et que l'une des premières choses
qu'elle fera que ce soit la gauche où
que ce soit nous qui gagnons la première
chose qu'elle fera c'est de faire un
collectif budgétaire pour réadapter le
budget aux exigences nouvelles qu'elles
apparaîtront à la nouvelle majorité est
perçu à l'opposition nous je n'ai donc
ceci est une fausse querelle trois
minutes il aura même pas de problème sur
le volet la question du fonds monétaire
international on va pas en parler
longtemps mais voudra vous deviendrez
alors je ne pense alors et vous n'aimez
pas parler de sous bon je n'aime pas
parler de votre vie privée vous un
avenir tout à fait le droit mais en même
temps les gens aiment bien un juge et
les hommes politiques qui sont amenés à
avoir des responsabilités alors avec
vous on a toujours un petit peu le
sentiment que la politique prend un
parfum est un guerrier si vous voulez
que tout ça est belliqueux cas des
controverses musclé est ce que est ce
que vous êtes un homme tolérant des
jeunes et il faudra lire le contrat que
je ne crois pas le voorpost contraire et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je n'aime
pas répondre à ce type de questions qui
n'ont en réalité pas de sens ce n'est
pas à moi qu'il faut demander si c'est
ce que tous les ans les questions qu'on
se pose pas moi oui ça ne sais pas moi
qu'il faut demander si je suis tolérant
c'est à ceux qui me connaissent je n'ai
pas eu le sentiment de faire dans ma vie
publique des actes d'intolérance
je suis en tous les cas je peux vous le
dire profondément respectueux de la
tradition républicaine et de la
transition démocratique pour moi c'est
tout à fait essentiel et cela me conduit
à affirmer très clairement qu'il n'y a
qu'un seul souverain que je reconnaisse
que nous reconnaissions et qui est le
peuple et d'où la nécessité de sanctions
européennes et son gisement qui en toute
hypothèse doit être suivi ça c'est une
chose qui est claire quand la tolérance
je n'ai pas du tout le sentiment de vous
quelqu'un de tolérant
si je l'étais je ne serai pas élu en
corrèze qui est un vieux pays
républicain où la tradition je dirais la
grande tradition française de la
révolution française est restée
profondément vivace et qui comporte un
double aspect qu'on oublie trop souvent
c'est d'une part celui de la tolérance
et le respect d'autrui sans aucun doute
et d'autre part c'est le respect de la
nécessaire autorités dans la démocratie
car la démocratie est un régime de
tolérance mais c'est aussi un régime
d'autorité dans la mesure où c'est un
régime qui est fondée sur la
souveraineté populaire laquelle
s'exprime par ses représentants et c'est
la loi mais à partir du moment où le
peuple s'est prononcé par la loi la loi
doit être respectée et pour la faire
respecter il faut de l'autorité
c'est la raison pour laquelle lorsqu'il
ya crise d'autorité dans une démocratie
lorsqu'il y a laissé aller lorsqu on les
conduit à laisser faire ou dire
n'importe quoi à ce moment là on court
un grave un grave danger c'est la
démocratie qui court un grave danger
sachez bien que il n'y a pas de
contradiction entre la démocratie et
l'autorité oublier quand l'une des deux
va pas sans l'autre
didier quentin crise d'autorité ya crise
d'autorité en ce moment aux militants
contestent pas en france dont la plupart
non parce que j'imagine qu'ils adressent
de l'histoire des démocraties actuelles
il y a incontestablement crise
d'autorité y compris en france y compris
en france et cette crise d'autorité qui
se traduit par un certain nombre
d'éléments qui peuvent paraître des
éléments de libéralisme sont des
éléments qui sont profondément dangereux
pour la tradition républicaine et
démocratique car je le répète la
démocratie c est aussi à l'origine
d'autorité c'est également un régime de
tolérance est ce que vous croyez que les
français peuvent partir tranquilles en
vacances à gauche je ne vois vraiment
pas en dehors des prévisions
météorologiques dont j'ai appris qu'elle
n'était pas très satisfaisante je
souhaite que pour une fois les experts
se soit trompé mais en dehors de cela je
ne vois pas ce qui pourrait provoquer
des difficultés aux français pendant les
vacances
compte non tenu naturellement des
problèmes sociaux et notamment de ceux
de l'emploi sont au point des rangs des
préoccupations de tous monsieur chirac
je vous remercie d'avoir passé cette
heure avec nous pour cartes sur table la
prochaine émission de cartes sur table
aura lieu le mois prochain le 13 juillet
avec alain duhamel à 20h30 comme ce soir
merci bonsoir
[Musique]